[Music]  all I can do is apologize on the  bachelors live after the final rose  special re lion Dec junior had to face  the music  24 hours earlier fans had seen him dump  his fiancee Becca kufran to pursue his  runner-up Lauren Burnham do you think  that you're 100% Oh Rebecca yes thousand  percent so how did he explain himself he  said he regretted proposing to Becca and  why did you well he kind of blamed the  franchise I think the pressure of this  the pressure of being the bachelor  knowing that there's a time line and  having to make that decision on that day  but you always have a choice and you  didn't need to make that choice I know  and I own up to that that's on me  that is totally on me I have no excuse  for that I I apologize for that  and then he left viewers with this in a  day I'm just trying to sort out what's  best in my life  all before proposing to Burnham yes this  means re proposed to two different women  in one season  [Music]